for a dozen years here in the UK he was
a red top newspaper editor in the chair
at both the news of the world and the
Daily Mirror few were better placed to
talk about the culture of the tabloid
press and very quickly he was tackled
about phone hacking when he was an
editor was was this a practice which was
taking place within the daily mirror
before 2004 I do not believe so no you
don't believe so or you're sure I don't
believe so to the best of my
recollection I do not believe sir piers
morgan was questioned about the jailing
of the news of the world's former royal
editor clive goodman the magazine
interview with the supermodel naomi
campbell back in 2007 he said lobes of
newspaper journalists were doing it
clive goodman has been made the
scapegoat for a very widespread practice
you were making statements there which
would select suggest at least that you
were basing yourself on personal
knowledge even if what other people
might have told you wouldn't you agree
ah no I wouldn't agree but why did you
say make it work he was made the
scapegoat for very widespread practice
why would have thought the subsequent
events our son he was made the scapegoat
before my editor also wrote an article
in The Daily Mail about Paul McCartney's
troubled relationship with his former
wife heather mills in which mr. Morgan
appeared to have listened to a hacked
phone message at one stage I was played
a tape of a message Paul had left for
Heather on her mobile phone he said it
was heartbreaking he sounded lonely
miserable and desperate and even saying
we can work it out into the answer phone
tell you listen to all of that did you
know that that was unethical not an
ethical alone why not the stock doesn't
necessarily follow the listening to
somebody speaking to somebody else is
unethical the only person who would
lawfully be able to listen to the
message is the lady in question or
somebody
authorized on her behalf to listen to it
isn't that right possibly but I am
perfectly happy to call a lady McCartney
to give evidence as to whether she
authorized you to listen to her
voicemails but as on his TV shows Piers
Morgan insisted on the last word this
has got how I thought he would which is
it becomes like it almost like a rock
star having an album ruled out from his
back catalogue of all his worst ever
hits and I do feel still very proud of a
lot of the very good stuff that both the
mirror and the news of the world did in
my tenure as editor in the end mr.
Morgan's confident persona just about
got him through his transatlantic
evidence session thank you very much
thank you very much thank you but it was
an uncomfortable couple of hours who
Britain's most famous six editor
evidence every boat in stands